[Music]
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents public policy forums a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us
today's topic art sales a useful foreign
policy tool an examination of arms sales
or arms transfers if you will as a tool
of foreign policy must inevitably
recognize the potential of such sales to
affect the economic military
psychological as well as the diplomatic
posture of the recipients more in each
of these areas the recipients posture
plays a part
large or small but always important in
the grand design of US policy to protect
crucial American interests and those of
our allies in Western Europe the Middle
East Africa Asia and South America our
discussion of arms sales to be sure is
concerned solely with conventional arms
not atomic weapons but a vital factor is
the extraordinary sophistication which
has developed in conventional arms in
this electronic era and the potential
hazards to our own overall security if
these sophisticated elements are in the
hands of nations whose borders lie in
the volatile areas of confrontation
between the interests of the United
States and her allies and the Soviet
Union in mid 1981 the Reagan
administration announced its arms
transfer policy emphasizing that the
quote basic thrust is to recognize that
arms transfers properly considered and
employed represent an indispensible
instrument of American policy that both
complements and supplements the role of
our own military forces
end quote this is a marked change of
direction from Carter administration
policy emphasizing restraint and primary
consideration of a recipients human
rights policies in approving arm sales
well to examine the question mark on our
arm sales issue we have a highly expert
panel to my far right lieutenant general
Brent Scowcroft a West Point graduate
who holds some doctorate in
international relations from Columbia
University served with the Joint Chiefs
of Staff and after retiring from the
service was assistant to President Ford
for national security affairs to my
immediate right representative William L
Dickinson Republican from Alabama and
ranking minority member of the House
Armed Services Committee and
Subcommittee on research and development
to my immediate left Senator Joseph R
Biden of Delaware member of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee senator
Biden served as chairman of the US
Senate delegations on salt - in Moscow
and to the North Atlantic Assembly in
Ottawa in nineteen hundred and
seventy-nine to my far left
representative les aspin sixth term
Democrat from Wisconsin with a doctorate
in economics from MIT dr. Aspen earlier
served as an economist with the Pentagon
now is a member of the Armed Services
and budget committees of the house well
to begin gentlemen I would pose the same
question to each of you in turn to what
extent should an arms transfer or sales
program play a role in our foreign
policy
senator Biden well it seems to me that
we have an expression those of us who
practice law before coming to the
Congress that hard cases make bad law I
think it's very difficult to make
sweeping statements and generalities
about arms control policy but to the
extent that one must be made it seems to
me that the US should have a restraint
we both be both restrained and prudent
in in making arms transfers and arms
sales while at the same time recognizing
that in particular circumstances they
can be very vital and important to US
interest there are instances where arms
transfers are in fact
absolutely essential for us interest and
others where we have made bad or
incorrect judgments about the stability
of the nations to whom we are
transferring their arms and failed in
other instances to factor in the arms
transfer as part of the overall foreign
policy determination for a region or a
country so it's a it's sort of a mixed
bag
I think it's neither indispensable as
this administration says nor should it
have been an exceptional tool of foreign
policy as the last administration
indicator representative Dickinson I
agree in the main was what the senator
said whether we like it or not it is an
instrument of foreign policy and you
cannot escape it that being so the best
thing we could do and what we should do
is to use it as Senator Biden said in a
very prudent manner but whether we're
talking about our friends now eyes or
potential adversaries we are going to
have to influence our foreign policy
with the use of weapons sales just as
the Soviets do just as the French do and
I don't advocate an arms race but to to
say that it is not an instrument of it
is to ignore the obvious representative
aspirin I agree I think that there's no
question that it is an instrument
whether we like it or not there it is
what makes it so difficult is that there
is an ethical and a moral dimension to
arms sales as well as a national
security dimension it's not unlike human
rights in that way it's a complicated
issue where you've got ethics and
morality competing with national
security considerations which means I
think two things number one it's very
difficult to take an extreme position
either totally for arms sales are
totally against and secondly it's very
very difficult to be totally consistent
you may find two similar cases in one
case you want to sell arms another case
you know all in all it's a very
difficult subject to deal with general
Scowcroft I think it's a rather rather
important as a instrument of u.s.
foreign policy after
there are relatively few such
instruments that we have we have
diplomatic policy economic policy
economic aid and arms transfers if you
will
arms transfers are unique in the sense
that whether we like it or not the world
in which we live is one in which power
is a primal element and where that is
the case insecurity is also an important
element and arms sales in addition to US
military policy itself US military
guarantees and so on
serves a indispensible role in lessening
the kind of insecurity that the world in
which we live in produces right we're
examining a change in direction in arms
transfer policy President Carter
launched a restraint policy a unilateral
effort to reduce arms transfers to the
third world with a multi-billion dollar
ceiling but a set of guidelines
hopefully setting a good example to
other arms suppliers and he also had a
multilateral effort launched in
discussions with European nations and
formal negotiations with the Soviet
Union even earlier the Congress had
restricted arms transfers and assistance
personnel by numbers by control of
credit by the nature of the recipient
regimes etc but both of these efforts it
seems bore little fruit what went wrong
general Scowcroft would you start well I
think they bore little fruit because I
think they were well-meaning but
fundamentally misguided and that is they
operated on the premise the simple and
in many ways comforting premise that
arms create Wars and that therefore it's
intrinsically and evil and should be
engaged in only when our overriding
national interests involved and it seems
to me that fundamentally misses a point
long before there were complicated
weapon systems long before there was
gunpowder
there was war conflict is older than
recorded history
and it's deeply rooted in the nature of
man and it seems to me that arms and
arms races really represent the
thermometer not the disease and that
we're not likely to cure the disease by
breaking the thermometer now I think
certainly a lot of our friends use arms
or one arms for purposes we do not
consider overriding nevertheless are we
really to set ourselves up as the judge
of the fundamental national interests of
our friends and it seems to me that the
answer to that question is fundamentally
what was wrong with with the policy of
the previous administration may I I
think I disagree with the general at
least some degree I I would I would
suggest that the real issue is not
whether or not nations in effect would
fight anyway and I think the general is
correct I mean whether or not they had
Sam missiles provided by the Soviet
Union or whether or not they had
sophisticated airplanes supplied it but
supplied by the United States or France
if they didn't have those that use
slingshots or rocks or bow and arrows or
whatever but I do think US national
interest is impacted upon significantly
depending on the degree to which this of
sophistication of the weaponry for
example it is much less likely that a
conflict that is limited to obsolete
tanks and old m1 rifles or their
counterparts or Remington rifles is
going to embroil a whole region of the
world and in fact bring the United
States into a confrontation it would
otherwise like to avoid there by either
bringing in the Soviets or the Soviets
first making it a east-west
confrontation I think that the extent to
which that occurs at least in some part
depends upon the degree of
sophistication of the weapons the reason
why the Congress
got in the business of saying that we
want to have at least to say in that
because it is a component of foreign
policy was because it went from 1.7
billion to somewhere in the order of 16
million in a matter of four years and it
looked as though to some of us that was
becoming the almost assault criteria for
determining what reach we would have
abroad and I am much more Makaveli and I
guess then my friend the general and in
fact I do think if we are transferring
arms we should first and foremost
conclude whether or not it impacts
favorably on our national interest if it
does and yet it does not impact on their
interest I would vote to send the arms
if it does not yet it does favorably
impact on them I would be inclined not
to send the arms that's an
oversimplification and last point in
regard to transfers there are two
elements of the transfers we compete not
only with our Soviets friends they are
our enemy they are in fact engaged in
confrontation in various levels and
stages throughout the world and we are
engaged with them but we are also
engaged with our allies and it seems to
me that one of the things we have missed
and one of the things is chairing the
European Committee for some years now in
the Senate is that we are somewhat timid
about speaking to our allies firmly
about what we are what the quid pro quo
for them doing such and such is and so
we tend to say we we say we are as
helpless in dealing with French sales
which may be true British sales or any
other ally as we are with Soviet sales
of third world countries and I think we
should at some point at least in the
Congress address whether or not we are
have have been tough enough where we can
be tough let me agree with something
that some of what general Scowcroft said
and some of what senator Biden said I
think that it's true that the arms do
not create the conflict the conflict was
there before the arms that the conflict
will go on whether we provide the arms
or not that
who are we to judge their national
security interests I they have to look
at their own national security interests
but we it's our decision as to whether
we are to sell them a particular weapon
or weapons system and I think that given
the limited leverage implied by your
statement which I agree with that we
have limited leverage even if we do
provide them the arms that we had better
make pretty sure that their national
security interests at least in the use
of that weapon is is consistent with
ours congressman Dickinson well I don't
know that I can add much to this this
particular point except to underscore
the fact that we do sell arms should be
to promote our national interests not to
help that country necessarily if I have
in that country we promote our interests
yes but then getting back to lessons
point I don't know that we can properly
put ourselves in the role of the judge
and say well we don't believe that this
is in your national interest so country
of Chile and we won't sell you a
sophisticated airplane so they go and
buy a Mirage from France or we say to
South Africa we don't like your internal
politics we need you strategically we
need your minerals but we won't sell you
a submarine so what do they do they go
to France and by submarines we don't
denied anything except we've put a
strain on relationship and maybe to the
point of breach it some yes at some time
but you see when you when you talk about
weapons sales that's just a part of it
and there is a pending deal now with
Saudi Arabia about eight point five
billion dollars well if you break that
down only about two billion two to three
is actually a photo for weapons the rest
of it is going into hospital
it goes into the infrastructure it goes
to train people there people come over
here we go over there there's a cultural
exchange and so there's a very large
ripple effect and I just pick Saudi
because they have the largest pending
sale now but in countries around the
world all of these ripple effects are
very important to us and so we have to
look at what is our national interest
and very very difficult it's very
difficult to say well we won't sell it
to you and then force them go someplace
else
well I think it goes without saying
senator that our national interest is
what we're concerned about not the
national interest of the recipient but
presumably our national interest is
involved in making them feel more secure
for some purpose that we that we have in
mind and it's that that I meant when we
say you don't really need those things
we don't we want to help you were your
friend but you don't really need those
weapons and it's it's that that I think
gets over to the point to congressman
Dickinson has two brief points with
regard to that first of all it seems to
me that that a point that congressman
Dickinson just made take South Africa
for an example and the implication is
because South Africa went to an ally
France or will go to an ally France to
get the same thing we wouldn't sell them
that somehow that doesn't benefit us
particularly let me suggest that that
may be of immense benefit to us let's
assume that one of the one of the
downsides I think we'll all agree
potential downside doesn't always occur
but one of the downsides when it occurs
of an arms transfer to a another country
may very well be that we feel we have to
because of security reasons give aid
military aid but we know we're going to
suffer a propaganda price for having
done so so I would suggest that in a
sophisticated arms transfer policy and I
realize I'm coming off as the young
prince here of Makaveli but I would
suggest that sometimes it makes sense
for us to forego the downside which is
the propaganda loss is a consequence of
a transfer to what we would acknowledge
is a regime that doesn't particularly
values compatible with what we view ours
to be and yet accomplish the same goal
by having an ally move and fill that
vacuum second point is that with regard
to the question of insecurities of
foreign countries I think one of the
problems that we sometimes face
Democratic and Republican
administrations has been that we fuel
the insecurities of insecure leaders we
give them a false sense of security by
the transfer of arms I can think of no
greater case in point than Iran I think
of no instance in the recent history
fright frankly the history over the
United States of America in transfer of
arms where we in fact kidded ourselves
and allowed the Shah to kid himself here
we had third close to 30 billion dollars
where the most sophisticated arms in the
world and not a shot was fired not a
single shot that I'm aware of
he was marched out of the country his
successor was marched out of the country
in all those weapons are either lying
dormant or and or have become they have
been accessed by the KGB and the Soviet
Union and or are being prepared to be
used in a way if they ever get their act
together that maybe inimicable to our
interest we're now told with regard to
Saudi Arabia the reason why we should
sell them certain weapons including
AWACS is because there's a runway in
Iran and Iran has those F and well we'll
go through all the weaponry but Iran has
those weapons that can take off be
across the Gulf in a matter of minutes
and now we have to supply a nation with
sophisticated weaponry to shoot down the
sophisticated weaponry we gave an
insecure leader who we should have known
we were just feeding his insecurities if
we had been willing to look beyond our
own intelligence apparatus training of
their intelligence apparatus through
whom we got the advice that's an
overstatement I'm afraid but that's the
tendency of some very interesting
general would you like to yes I think
it's a substantial overstatement and it
seems to me that recent events in Iran
if they've shown anything it's the
situation with the Shah is far more
complicated than it appeared at the time
in 1971 when the British pulled out of
the Gulf
we had three ways to go
we could try to keep them there and
subsidizing we could replace them with
our own forces or we could try to create
a bastion of strength there
we chose the third now I suggest that it
was highly successful and that while a
Shaw was there the Gulf was stable there
wasn't a war between Iran and Iraq it
didn't cost us anything as a matter of
fact economically it benefited us I I
think it's a moot point how much it did
or did not have to do with the Shahs
fall but afterwards what have we had to
replace the Shah with two carrier task
forces an RDF that we're trying to fund
billions of dollars that is going to
cost the United States to replace what
we had in the shop I don't destroy RDF
being a rapid deployment force what are
the hazards of having sophisticated
weaponry of the kind that that we did
transfer me it was all of that weapons
that we sold the Shah necessary to play
the role that general Scowcroft is
saying that we wanted the Shah to play I
think that the that the point is correct
that we were looking for a substitute
for the Brits we were looking for
somebody to provide some stability area
but does that mean f-14s DD 963
destroyers I mean does the whole baggage
have to come with that my answer to that
would be no I mean there's a role to
play there was a and arm sails would
have been part of it but all of these
extremely sophisticated weapons I think
I you could argue that it it made his
military force less effective than it
might have been it stretched their
technology their technical people very
very thin
we never know because of course the the
the Shahs Army and Air Force and Navy
was never put to the test they it would
crumble from within rather than
defeated never we so we never know but
but I think that the you don't have to
sell them everything to follow the
policy that you're advocating I wouldn't
disagree with that and I think
reasonable people can't can disagree
over weapons weapons system by weapons
systems when I representative Dickinson
raised very briefly an issue that became
a cause celebrity the Saudi Arabian
purchase which included the AWACS this
is an area in which we are caught
between the nether and the near
millstone it's almost impossible to come
out of it without making somebody upset
at us is this an area that is so common
and constant in this field that we
really should shrink from the the whole
arms transfer business as much as
possible because of the the problems
they can raise I think there's one thing
that's part of this is that there's
maybe an asymmetry here that you don't
get much from selling it but you might
get a lot a lot if you if you announce
that you're going to thinking about
selling it and then denied the sale and
I think that that's part of the arms
sale problem is this asymmetry that it
that by selling it you may get a little
bit of leverage we may get some goodwill
we may gain a little bit but the
downside if you don't sell it turns out
to be enormous with these countries I
mean they take it as a personal affront
and a rejection and I think that's what
gets us into trouble is is that we make
these deliberations in public as we as
you do but but if the decision turns out
negative it can have severe consequences
I don't disagree with that but I would
like to add one point about Saudi Arabia
I think Saudi Arabia falls into the
category that I I arbitrarily said I
thought there were two categories one
where if we don't supply an ally will
supply and the other one is if we don't
supply the Russians are coming they're
gonna move in and they're gonna become
the supplier and we're gonna have a
reverse Ethiopia Somalia or Egypt
they're all the places we can know where
we've each been suppliers and one moves
out and one moves in
in in the case of Saudi Arabia I think
that there is no more complicated part
of the world in the Middle East nowhere
not many I think to disagree with that
and we have what appeared to be appear I
emphasize conflicting foreign policy
goals and the transfers of this of
sophisticated weaponry to either the
Israel or to any Arab state in this case
the the Saudis can further complicate
that so that we started off I thought or
we I think we should start off with
saying is is our our arms transfers a
part of foreign policy and I think that
the problem we have in the Middle East
is the determination of our foreign
policy now foreign policy can be
complicated by an arms transfer let me
just give you one case in point why I
didn't think that sale should go forward
forget all the questions about whether
or not Israel is more or less secure or
whether and what it does whether it work
how much of an umbrella it presents
etcetera it seems to me that the the
Saudis have been very deft at seen to it
that they give little more than lip
service to involvement in any Mideast
war up to now they've essentially said
to the Rav friends when they said jump
on with us they've said we will send
money we wish you luck we'll pray at the
mosque for you and and so on but now it
seems to me because the interest we're
looking to protect there is oil to the
Western world in Japan I mean I think
we're gonna be this fairly naked we're
in a situation where I think the sale of
this sophisticated weaponry makes Saudi
Arabia a valuable ally to the rest of
the Arab world if there is confrontation
and failure to join the cause and engage
that weaponry if confrontation occurs I
think will result in what is the most
likely thing to occur and that is
internal espionage and sabotage those
wells being blown up by some of the two
million Palestinians who run them now
anyway and the end result will be the
foreign policy initiative we were
setting out to protect that is free
access to that oil may very well be
hindered instead of helped by the
transfer that was coca I
I wonder if that's really the case the
first place the Saudis have given token
health before it seems to me in the in
the 67 war they sent a brigade or a
battalion and I'm not sure it ever got
there they only been Tokyo that's right
they have done things and I'm not sure
that that would not be the case in any
future cause as a matter of fact I'd say
the reverse would be true that it would
be involved mostly because the Israelis
might feel it was vital to take out that
AWACS in case a war started I think
that's you know that that's a
possibility
military planner wouldn't you assume
that if you're under Israeli planner
wouldn't you assume if there's a war
that those f-15s are not gonna sit on a
runway and those AWACS are not gonna be
just focused on the east and that you
better hit first I mean you're you're a
general I mean wouldn't you sit there
and say that's the logical thing to do
I would certainly make plans for it but
the Israelis have not hit all the Arab
targets that they had the capability hit
in previous Wars but none have had as
the ones they haven't hit have not had
the potential capability to wreak havoc
on them that the weaponry we are now
selling will and does that's the only
point that's true but you know but this
may be a case which in a sensory future
argument about the sophistication being
an evil in fact it may be a benefit here
because the equipment is so
sophisticated and that may be the case
in a number of case that it cannot
usefully be operated without American
help which gives us additional leverage
to ensure unlike m1 rifles and grenades
and so on that they don't need any help
for it gives us additional leverage in
the way that those weapons will be used
it seems to me that we completely ignore
and look aside at the real issue but if
we talk about a wax and is how is it in
our best interest and what action should
we take well we are almost governed
that's the wrong or too strong word but
we the the Israeli government and the
supporters of Israel have an inordinate
impact on our Congress and that's really
what we're not the president has said is
in is in the interest in the United
States Secretary Hague is said is in the
interest if you look to see the history
of Saudi in the past few years and the
friendship they have offered us and I'm
talking about
OPEC now OPEC was just trying to raise
their price from 32 dollars to 36
dollars a barrel
it was the Saudis that kept them from
doing that they have done at it or at
least three different occasions it was
the Saudis that kept the Jordanians and
others that wanted OPEC to go off the
dollar standard onto another monetary
exchange so there have been in a number
of instances when we have been the
beneficiary of the friendship of the
Saudis and to for us to say that it's
not in our interest to continue the
friendship and to give them a defensive
capability and that's what we're talking
about here not in fear but there 15 is
but in a wax I think we've been
particularly short-sighted and I'm
certain supported well they can't let
them go by I think that it's it's
important that when you look at what the
Saudis have done with oil prices what
they've done in the economic sphere it's
it's very clear that they have not done
anything that is not out of line with
their own self-interest there's what
about keeping the prices down you think
absolutely absolutely absent what all of
the other nations have wanted to raise
it that's right but they they perceived
it in their own self-interest to keep
the oil prices down because if the
prices go up the substitution for oil in
the industrial
Westby comes quicker their resources of
oil in their cut in there in the ground
becomes obsolete quicker but I don't
think you can look at anything in the
oil and the economic sphere and make a
case that Saudi Arabia is doing us any
favors I mean they may have been doing
us some favors as a byproduct of doing
themselves some favors what would be
really impressive to me would be if they
would throw their weight in behind the
Camp David Accords now that would be
impressive and in that case that might
change my view about things like sale of
the F it well the away all right if I
could just add one point it seems to me
we have another interest in the a waxes
in Saudi Arabia aside from from from
what you've discussed and that is a u.s.
national interest protect our own forces
over there
right you know we used to have
long-range radar in Iran that could
monitor the Soviet Union in any Soviet
attack our battle fleets there are
potentially very vulnerable to Soviet
air attack and it seems to me that the
AWACS serves a very important role and
is right now in giving us early warning
but generally you know better than I do
I just spent two days out at their day
out of Tinker Air Force Base and spent
all kinds of time in the Intelligence
Committee the AWACS flown within the
boundaries of Saudi Arabia does not give
us any warning that has anything
comparable to that which in fact existed
in Iran we have a very limited ability
as broad as it is to be able to detect
whether or not there is a Soviet move
and and and it is really is not even
remotely comparable to the Iranian
absolutely but it is a great deal better
than the self protection right and we
have it now we carry more AWACS there
they are flying now they're American
cruise they're controlled by America and
and what are their at Saudi sufferance
as we do well I think we've gone into
there I'd like to come back to the fact
that since 72 the Congress has with some
assertiveness move to try to redo
this issue of arms transfers I wonder if
the efforts of past administrations and
the Congress have not produced a
labyrinth and maze of administrative
processes some elements of this program
to go through state the Defense
Department's the Joint Steve Chiefs of
Staff the individual services the
Treasury Department the agency of
international development the Central
Intelligence Agency the Office of
Management and Budget and we constructed
a system which is just incapable of
flexible response to volatile and
ever-changing worlds Congress bill a lot
of these initially what a you this your
you were in the Congress actually
through all this from 72 to 77 when all
that legislation was going through it
doesn't work I think we all seem to
agree that doesn't work in the sense
that arms sales have continued to
increase what you we have done is as you
say set up a rather elaborate procedure
in which the Congress must approve and
and you have got various players and in
the in the field but once you set up a
procedure like that it's it's hard to be
sure that the thing wouldn't have would
have gone exactly the same without that
procedure yes Congress has never voted
down an arm sales that has been proposed
has an administration ever been
dissuaded from proposing an arm's sale
because of this procedure and in the end
the fear that Congress might turn it
down you know I I think it's very hard
to prove conclusively that there's been
a total failure could actually chance
unless that I it seems to me that there
are two reasons for the the labyrinth as
you refer to it that the Congress set up
one has been I think noticeably and
unsuccessful and one has been very
successful the first reason was that we
hoped everyone hoped I think that who
was participated in it that it would in
fact cut down in terms of the gross
quantity of weaponry and dollars
represented in that weapon
it was transferred to that extent on a
on a chart that you would draw and the
dollars of weapon value transferred it
hasn't been very successful but a second
and I believe more important reason why
and I was there from 72 on we were doing
this also in the Senate was the foreign
policy component of it because at the
outset of this program we all said the
one thing we all agree on it is a tool
of foreign policy and what happened was
we had presidents Democrats and
Republicans over the previous 15 to 20
or our history who were in fact treating
what was viewed as an economic decision
independent of the foreign policy
consideration that the Congress said we
now want to be part of and to that
extent I think it's successful and has
been successful in the sense you you may
argued Congress wasn't right but it's
been successful that accomplished what
Congress set out to do and that is be
part of the game
generals go crow I think I think
Congress ought to be involved in these
kinds of decisions they are
fundamentally foreign policy decisions I
think they were Congress really and this
is very difficult to do ought to be
involved at the policy stage though the
problem I have with the present
procedures is it's too late when you all
get it and you cannot reject a proposal
of the event of an administration
without doing Grievous foreign policy
harm that's the problem I think we've
covered a lot of ground and perhaps race
good number of questions among our
friends in the audience
so it's time for the question and answer
session may I have the first question
please I noticed all kinds of concerns
and effects so arms transfers but did
not find anyone saying anything about
the domestic affects both economic and
in our military preparedness about 50%
of our companies have been manufacturing
goods for foreign sales which is about
the only thing that's kept our own
industry alive in the defense products
area
all right who'd like stereo I would
think it to start with yeah
you're exactly correct in our arms sales
has a very wide impact economically in
this country as a matter of fact I was
reading some I don't know how
authoritative it is but some 50,000
families depended on the sales to Saudi
Arabia alone in this proposed package I
don't know who put out that propaganda
but it is very very wide and I was just
in a defense plant on the West Coast
last week and they were there making
armored personnel or vehicles and they
don't they don't have any sales to this
country now they are going to Spain they
go into Israel they're going to in a
number of other countries but that's
what's keeping them going as you said so
there is a very broad if we lost all our
foreign military sales right now the
unemployment rate would go up
substantially in this country genna's go
craft well I don't think there's any
question that that it is helpful to
American industry and also our own armed
forces it cuts substantially the unit
cost of of some of our equipment but
I'll be something of our iconic class I
do not think that our arms sale policy
ought to be dictated by our domestic
economic means I think got to be
dictated by our national interest and
solely on that basis you're also one
other point minor point in this thing
and that is that that yes there are
cases where we have sold arms abroad
where there was no demand in the
American armed forces for that equipment
so it did keep people at work there are
also cases and probably more now if
we're into a build-up phase in the US
military where you've got competing
claims where the US military also wants
the equipment and the arms sales are
competing to pin and you get the
question of who gets it first yeah I can
think of a few so so it cuts both ways
in that regard now that's true I would
like to add one point
one additional point and I think the
gentleman's the questioners point is
well-taken it does positively impact
upon our balance of trade situation but
it is one of the potential upsides to
arms sales but to reiterate general
scrotus ASCO cross point if in fact we
have a circumstance where it becomes the
motivating force behind the sale not
only have we sometimes not had
production military equipment that our
military no longer needed what we've
tended to do is our arms merchants have
decided to go sell what is also not
needed by the third country that
particular weapon system that has
occurred too so it's a double-edged
sword yeah yeah all right next question
please yes my name is Bill wickersham
with the world Federalist Association I
would direct this to congressman Aspen
most of the panelists indicated that
they think the United States should act
in its own self-interest which probably
very few people would disagree question
is if 159 or so other nations around the
world act in the same way and if in fact
the weaponry becomes more sophisticated
and it becomes dispersed throughout the
world and if in fact as several studies
including some United States government
studies suggest there will be nuclear
capability within some 29 or 30 nations
by let's say year 2004 sure how do we
contain this so it's not combustible and
that we the whole thing explodes that is
a very good question I think that the
phenomenon that you're talking about is
a very serious one and a very real one
if you look at the amount of money spent
on arms in the world and just plot that
over a number of years it's really
reaching staggering proportions I'm not
sure that you can stem that tide with an
arm sales policy alone
if you had an across-the-board policy
which i think is unwise to take an
extreme position of not selling anything
to anybody no matter what
i-i think you would be making a not
terribly significant dent on that race i
think those the the factors that go into
arms races are factors that have to do
with in national states that are
rivalries with their neighbors competing
ideologies competing religions all of
these things and the the impact of arms
sales on that is is a factor but it but
a relatively minor one which and and i
think that that the problem is is that
people tend to look at arm sales as a
good tool to stem that that big race and
and and my problem is is i don't think
it will work and you're putting an awful
lot of weight on a very thin read to try
and accomplish it through through
through our sales go through eliminating
arm sales sorry if i could just give one
example there's one case where we where
we really tried to do this and that was
Latin America in the 1960s the Alliance
for Progress we made a policy decision
that we were not going to sell any arm
any sophisticated arms we were not going
to upgrade any of the equipment to Latin
American countries had it was a
relatively stable period in Latin
America the competition between and
among the countries was a low level most
of their equipment especially their
airplanes tanks and so on were obsolete
we stuck to that during during almost
all of the sixties the result was that
they bought arms in the British bought
arms from the French and they bought
arms from the Russians
and now maybe in an ideal world we could
get together with our allies and even
with the Russians which the Carter
Administration were trying to put an end
to that sort of thing but as a practical
matter we don't have very much leverage
mr. Wickersham you implicit in your
statement at least as I heard it was
that there's an inconsistency between a
transfer of arms are between potentially
between us self-interest and world
harmony
and I would suggest that that if that is
part of your implicit in your statement
that that is not correct I think we're
at a stage where what one of my
colleagues southern colleagues in the
Senate says it's wonderful when
conscience and convenience cross paths
and I think in arms control policy we
have the opportunity to have both
conscience and convenience cross paths
for example you mentioned nuclear
capability that is the overwhelming
concern for the entire world it seems to
me and there are instances where arms
transfer can diminish the prospect of
the feeling of urgency developed to
develop and/or steal and or whatever a
nuclear capability and conversely there
are cases which I believe is the
situation potentially in Pakistan where
massive arms transfers can propel the
competing countries in the region to
move toward the greater reliance on
nuclear so it it can work it can work to
the benefit on occasion and but that's
what I meant by I think we should do it
case-by-case next question please
my name is Richard derelict I'm
currently an international affairs
fellow with the Council on Foreign
Relations in New York I actually have
two questions they're interrelated the
first is if memory serves correct the
biggest market biggest business market
that the United States has in the world
for its arms sales policies is in fact
our allied market in principally our
NATO allied market that's where most of
the sales go on yet on the other hand as
I understand it NATO has various
policies itself to which we subscribe
policies like rationalization
standardization interoperability one
implication of which is that the allies
should be able to sell us more they have
learned the domestic effects and the
business benefits of of arms sales
themselves in the inter allied arena and
they like to oftentimes get in on the on
the act that creates however a certain
tension between a US policy which is
promoting sales to the Alliance and an
allied policy which one
reciprocity and my first question then
is how do we resolve this tension and is
there room excuse me for a new policy in
this general area my second question
arises from something I think senator
Biden said earlier and that was the
suggestion that sometimes allied arms
sales abroad are not necessarily
detrimental to us and they might
sometimes be encouraged I off I wondered
when you made that remark whether or not
this ally in general allied sales abroad
don't don't serve as a kind of safety
valve in some ways for the tension in
NATO the tension I described earlier and
I'm wondering if we have a u.s. policy
that on the one hand either tries to
control those sales more tightly as some
has haven't subscribe to the excuse me
ascribed to the previous administration
or a policy that tries to promote
American arms sales abroad more
vociferously particularly if you use an
anti allied argument if they don't sell
it we will if we don't sell it they will
in the process I wonder if in this
respect we don't run the risk of cutting
down or shorten short changing the
safety valve aspects of things and in
fact perhaps endangering the larger NATO
allied market which is where the real
money if you will often comes into play
so did Biden I think you're absolutely
correct you pose the problem very in a
very articulate manner I think we get
back to the the fundamental question
what is our foreign policy and what
should NATO be how should it be made up
and how effective is it and part of the
question of whether or not as effective
relates to the interoperability the
standardization standardization is not
merely motivated it is not primarily
motivated by the requirement of the
French to get in on the deal it's
motivated by the question that generals
know better than senators and that is
how do you have a unified battle plan
without having radios that can interview
that can receive one another's messages
without having spare parts that can be
interchanged without having tanks and
planes and guns etc that are
be used under a unified command somewhat
like a unified army and and that is the
motivating factor now once we reach that
decision
I think the Allies have a right to say
hey wait a minute now you ain't getting
it all we want a piece of that and I
think that we have to be willing to make
that decision there is a great deal of
pressure from our domestic arms
manufacturers to say no that we don't
want you quote giving away any of our
piece of the market I think just as
we've done in many other areas of
Foreign Relations we have to have the
courage and/or the foresight to say
we're going to figure out what component
what portion you're going to make up
United States what we're willing to what
piece we're willing to take absent that
there is a great risk being run in
cutting off the safety valve you are
absolutely correct because that's part
of the that that's part of the plan I
believe because we haven't been willing
to follow through on what is clearly in
our strategic and conventional interest
to do that is standardized and the
reason we haven't been able to do it is
be in large part is because of the
economic decisions involved in it
because of that we have propelled to a
greater degree our allies into markets
that compete with us in the third world
and many instances force us to make
decisions that are marginally less
detrimental than if we didn't move into
the area I think you said I think you
state it very well general Scowcroft I
agree with where the senator but I think
I think what we need to work on is the
NATO part rather than the safety valve
part because group you know NATO spends
more than the Warsaw Pact does on arms
and yet you know we're willfully behind
in preparedness one of the reasons is
that each country goes out and builds
its own little system they don't work
together they're not standardized and so
on we are one of the biggest culprits
not only for economic reasons but
military our own military tend to think
that unless unless it's our equipment
it's not good enough
and we have worldwide concerns not just
in NATO and therefore we have to have
our own sink equipment I think we need
to do far more and we need to take the
lead representative Dickinson I don't
disagree with what has been said I
thought maybe I would perhaps be helpful
to put it in a little different context
for the past few years I've been a
delegate to the North Atlantic Alliance
or assembly and this is the question
comes up there is an economic section of
political section and on military
section I'm working on the military
section and this question comes up every
time we meet well if we met six times a
year that's how many times have come up
this two-way street RSI and one of the
things that causes the breakdown is is
that our NATO allies say well look we're
buying more weapons from you than you
buying from us and so it's not fair and
the American reply is well look you're
not counting the cost of US stationing
our troops in Europe and if you put in
the cost of what we're spending the
station our troops in Europe to defend
you we're spending more than you're
spending so it's uh it goes round and
round but I think in the final analysis
for your major systems that I think the
answer is going to have to be what we
did with f-16 that is you're going to
break down and everybody that wants to
get in on the act all the countries they
make components and General Dynamics is
making part here and Belgians making
part there and it seems to be working
pretty well and rather than saying well
you will build this airplane and you
build that tank and we will swap out so
I think that down the road we're going
to find that's probably the most
practical way to go all right next
question the next question please on
major bill Hudson I'm the US Air Force
research associate Advanced
International Studies Institute
congressman Aspen indicated earlier he
felt that arms sales or arms transfers
actually had perhaps very little
leverage this seems to be the substance
of what the panel discussion is about I
wonder if you could all reply concretely
to the fact or to the opinion do you
think that arms transfers compared favor
other foreign policy tools diplomatic or
economic in achieving concrete results
such as basing rights or more generally
leverage or influence you want to start
I think that what I meant was that I
think leverage is very often overstated
and it's easy to anticipate a lot of
leverage when in fact the leverage may
not be very great and and I can think of
some examples one of the arguments is
that arm sales give us some control over
the use of those of that weapons because
if you keep control over the ammunition
and the spare parts you're then going to
have some the the country a little bit
on a leash as to as to whether the the
stuff gets used or not but there are
military engagements in which you don't
use up a lot of ammunition and spare
parts Israel bombed the Iraqi reactor
when one one swift blow and you may have
all the control over ammunition spare
parts and it doesn't doesn't give you
much leverage also countries have a way
of building up enough consumables I
think the Shah of Iran said about a
particular policy of trying to actually
build up enough consumables of
ammunition and spare parts for the very
purpose of shaking loose and getting a
little bit more flexibility I mean in
the old days back in the 50s we seem to
have a lot of leverage but back in the
50s there was more than arm sales we
were also giving economic grants and all
kinds of other economic aid and the
Russians were nowhere near as as
omnipresent as they are now and so we
had a great deal of influence but I
think people look back on that and think
that the arm sales gave us leverage when
in fact it was a it was a whole
constellation of aid and assistance and
underwriting them financially which gave
us the leverage it leverages a point but
I think it's very often overstated in
the arguments when it comes down to a
particular arms sale anybody want to add
anything to that slightly more than
then food through peace slightly less
than technology I think the question the
issue is more complicated than influence
if if by influence you mean we're buying
influence by selling arms and therefore
they'll do what we want I think the
answer is clearly no but it's a much
more subtle kind of an infinite
theoretically it helps these people with
their own purposes it gives them a
certain amount of self-confidence in
some cases it's vital to preserving the
military balance you take countries like
Korea for example were we to shut Korea
off you know the results could clearly
be disaster North Korea gives every
indication that if they thought they
could succeed they would attack Turkey
is another case where a clear military
necessity others are political but I
think I think you can't just look at
cause and effect I think it's much more
subtle and as congressman Osmond said
earlier many cases the influences is
purely negative and that is if you don't
do it you really disrupt one small
example of what the generals saying I
think in the School of the Americas
which is running Panama for to train of
military officers from Latin American
countries and in this country our
National War College air War College the
old series heaven we bring in foreign
students and they're the cream of the
crop from that country and and the
cultural exchange and the one-on-one
relationship that are developed then
have very long lasting because these are
the people who ultimately be in the
leadership of those countries and so
that's a dividend that you can't
overlook that most people really seem to
be unaware but I'm very much regret but
our time has run out and this concludes
another public policy forum presented by
the American Enterprise Institute for
Public Policy Research on behalf of a
EEI our hearty thanks to the expert
panelists general Brent Scowcroft
representative William L Dickinson
Senator Joseph R Biden Jr and rep
les Aspin and our thanks also to our
guests and experts in the audience for
their participation goodbye from
Washington it is the aim of AEI to
clarify issues of the day by presenting
many viewpoints in the hope that by
doing so those who wish to learn about
the decision-making process will benefit
from such a free exchange of informed
and enlightened opinion this public
policy forum series is created and
supplied to this station as a public
service by the American Enterprise
Institute Washington DC a AEI is a
nonprofit nonpartisan publicly supported
research and education organization
information on this and other subject
areas including government regulation
economic policy Social Security and
retirement health policy legal policy
tax policy political and social
processes energy policy defense policy
and international affairs is available
from the Institute for a transcript of
this program send $3.75 to the American
Enterprise Institute 11:50 17th Street
Northwest Washington DC 2 0 0 3 6
[Music]